I'm going to start with parametric
regression, which is a way of building
a model where we represent the model
with the number of parameters.
Let's start with a simple example.
Suppose we want to build a model that
will predict how much it will rain today
based on changes in barometric pressure.
So as you may know,
if barometric pressure declines,
that usually means there's bad
weather coming and it's going to rain.
And when barometric pressure increases,
it typically means that we've
got good weather coming.
So on this scatter plot each
individual point represents one day.
So let's consider a particular day,
say here.
And what this means is that on this day,
the barometric pressure decreased by 10
millimeters and we had 50
millimeters of rain, about 2 inches.
So let's consider that over time we
collect data for many different days and
that's what this looks like.
So again, each one of these dots
represents one day's worth of data and
we have multiple day's
worth of data here.
And as you can see there's a general
trend of as barometric pressure
decreases, we typically have more rain
and as it increases we have less rain.
We'd like to create a model based on
this data that when we query it at any
particular point it'll give us a
prediction of how much is going to rain,
so we would measure
barometric pressure or
its change and
then estimate how much is going to rain.
The classic solution to this problem
is to fit a line to the data.
So let's give that a shot.
As you probably know, this approach
is called linear regression.
And the model looks like this.
So if you remember, from algebra in
elementary school, or high school,
wherever you got it.
[LAUGH] The equation for
line is simply y equals mx plus b.
So x is our barometric
pressure change variable here,
and m and
b are the parameters of our model.
Our model now is fully described by
these two parameters, and if we want
to estimate or query how much it's
going to rain at any particular point.
We measure the barometric pressure.
Let's say the barometric
pressure today increased by 5.
We would then plug that 5
into our model here and
multiply it by m and add b.
And that's our estimate for
that day of how much it's going to rain.
And the linear regression approach
is how we arrive at m and b.
This model is decent, but
it doesn't track the actual
behavior of the data, for instance,
in this region and in this region,
so we can make a more complex model.
Instead of fitting a line we can fit
a polynomial, we can add one more term x
squared and now we've got to also
find this additional parameter m2.
So, when we find our model it's now
represented by three parameters
mm2 and b.
This polynomial model will
look something like this.
It fits the data pretty well over here,
but not so well over here.
Now, we can add more terms.
We can fit an x cubed term and
have another parameter and so on.
In general, these parametric
approaches come away with
a number of parameters, and the more
complex the model, the more parameters.
Still, three parameters
is a pretty simple model.
All of these models, whether it's
linear, with just mx plus b, or
polynomial, with a cubed or
squared term, are parametric models.
In the end, after we learn these models,
we have our parameters,
in this case, m2, m, and b.
And we throw away the data,
and the model's represented
just by these three parameters.
But there's another way to approach it,
and I'll show you that next.